[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je te jure j'ai ce qui me font dans
la vie non tu sais ce que tu fais voilà
ce qu'on va faire un jeu c'est ça on va
on va organiser un jeu et une ferrari ce
qu'on peut aller à l'école est tombé
lors ya un supermarché du dehors tu as
deux minutes pour acheter le maximum de
ce qui est mobile et dans le supermarché
une fois que tu pérenchies tour à deux
minutes pour prendre on n'est pas tout
ce qui est produits nécessité tu veux
tout ce que tu veux
ces courses associé avec monroe les
dessins et on a deux canines dans un an
vous avez tous bouffés vous db5 avec
deux caddies sinon si les gens rire de
nantes 2 2 minutes n'a pas tu as pu bien
que tu prends ce que tu veux d'accord tu
fous comme ça que j'aime de tenir dans
ces trois cas d'accord tu prouves avéré
dia keller sapa à ghlin iphone os 4 quoi
de neuf à partir dans deux minutes
d'accord le code bancaire et le code est
ce qu'il te plaît tant entendu la bonne
est-ce que tu as le code de quatre
chiffres le coach local les quatre
chiffres qui change la vie
le code aux nombreuses fautes shippagan
alors qu'un lien avec vous et je vais
prendre la personne ou vraiment je
prends la meilleure personne pour venir
et vous ouais vous allez y aller avec
on va vous avez deux minutes rayon
alcool écoute avec ciné concert pour
l'élan on donnera bien sûr tout ça bush
voilà merci à jean tirand dans le
magasin tu vas à gauche et les conserve
voilà mes 30 août magique oui mais c'est
un foutoir est simple à comprendre qu'un
de son père c'est william saurin sens
capable d'y aller avec lui bien sûr est
ce que tu veux alors moi manon turmel
mémoire de mémoire des gens on va vous
le donner alors vous le donner comme il
n'est pas seul il n'est pas seul car on
est amis on lui a mis un handicap et on
les a mis un handicap il est avec doc
gynéco et d'attention m'ont balancé le
chrono vous avez vous avez deux minutes
pour prendre ce que vous voulez dès
qu'il n'a pas les attentions
ben ouais ouais bravo oui ou alors
attention il faut qu'ils puissent
ramener tout ici sinon c'est pas validé
avec l'accord il aura ensuite une minute
pour tourner d'accord il fait 120
minutes dans le supermarché une minute
pour tours en elle s'ils ramènent tout
ici donc dans trois minutes ce sera
gagné attention à nier vous et près de 3
et
ok
oui
[Musique]
bah
ap
cohade r
[Musique]
la bête
allez alors ils sont déjà plus qu'une
minute quand on sait pas y croire mais
bien parce que je dis là c'est quand ce
n'était pas prévu qu'est ce qui se passe
le cadreur il est malade ou quoi est-ce
que vous avez déjà vu un cadreur filmer
la route frère chez nous y'a que ça
arrive
allez allez allez oui allez on y va
allez allez allez on y va on fait la
roue libre dans ses langes en retard est
ce qu on peut rappeler on est rentré à
l'état les sommes apple a plus qu'à
retrouver mathieu de la moi mais
l'avocat mais qu'est-ce qui fait il
encore alexis seconde à l'étang 45 ans
ils n'ont pas cherché notre match assez
de trucs mais là il a acheté trois trucs
et qui découvre qu'il est qu il aimait
comme l'espère aux heures venez regarder
ce match là qu'est l'école a laissé ma
carte la cache
ça va
comme ça
mais non alors ça y est c'est terminé
c'est terminé elle est aussi la leur
talent
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
el hadji malick
voyons
m
[Applaudissements]
nokia grands
alors les chaînes dont il est co voit là
bas il n'y a pas réussi ce défi
heureusement alors on va prendre tout
l'été sussac et perso pour moi de
m'adresser quoi c'est quoi qu'est ce
qu'il a acheté tout pour le petit déj
avait un truc pour la soirée
oui mais c'est vrai chez les deux styles
de jeu bon ce soir et non mais écoutez
on voit bien qu'il est au régime
ouais c'est demain matin voilà où il va
donc on le voit alors voilà attendez
regarder matthieu delormeau on va voir
ce qu'ils ont ramené il a ramené
beaucoup de riz ou beaucoup c'est bien
c'est beau comme au caudry on aura
également du riz mais vous avez mais il
a ramené du risque en l2 et qui n'est qu
il arrive et du riz et à y aller il ya
des friandises très bien beaucoup de
bien j'aime bien y'a du y est la vantus
cette fois les mettre tous sont égaux ya
derrière yvan que si on voulait tout est
distant mathieu voilà personne a confié
ville de vigueur après le défi les
sur-stocks gynéco
voilà la bonne chose allez vas y toi je
prends les choses il est également vous
donnera le nom du gagnant ou de la
gagnante dans un instant bravo à
matthieu delormeau
[Musique]